the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
the purpose of these recitations
small-group recitations is so that we
can get out the key concepts over the
week and what I call the essential
understandings you know what are the
really important points for the weeks of
it
when the first quiz comes you will know
how to deal with it so let's start with
that but you're going to do you're going
to help me think through this so take a
minute or two write down on a piece of
paper two or three things that you think
are the most important things that you
heard so I read this week about this
course
okay let's report out I want kind of one
from a number of you who wants to
volunteer here say it again using
different reference frames right I'm
gonna write that once I get chalk or
using I'm going to write it as multiple
reference frames close enough okay how
it what's your name Kristina what do you
have
okay
she sent all points on an object rigid
object that's rotating all points have
the same rotation rate so this is a
rotation and translation of rigid bodies
I'm going to generalize what you said a
little bit because the only but somebody
else tell me what can you say about
translation so rotation all points key
point is all points share the same
rotation rate
how about translation two different
points on an object what can you say
about it parallel paths default go
through exactly the same parallel paths
okay
so those are two key things remember
that how about another point okay this
is actually quite important this is I'm
going to write it slightly differently
we need to talk about this and that is
that rotations to be absolutely correct
finite rotations are not vectors I want
to come back to that in a minute
lots of possible confusion around that
now one more couple or actually is more
yeah-ah MLM so I've mentioned that last
time that's how that's problem-solving
my way which is M first M is figure out
the motion describe the motion that's
kinematics second M is not saying the
second second term is L what is that
laws it by the physical laws in the
second M do the math so motion laws and
math okay there's something else here
well this you may have decided it's
compass in that but I want to go a
little further than that
yeah what can you what do we talk a lot
about yesterday in lecture seller Asians
and velocities in translating and
rotating frames translating and rotating
frames running out of room here that you
get the point
all right that's a pretty good list if I
had been coming up a list on my own who
I would have thought it was important
that would have been would have captured
most of those things certainly this is
their really important this week
and we definitely need to learn how to
use translating rotating frames and
you're absolutely in trouble if you
don't know this you just sort of
fundamental to the whole thing okay and
then this is a subtle point let's bring
this start right there for a second
who has a gym you got a textbook it does
actually really matter let me borrow
your notes all right
rigid body got the print on the front
I'm going to rotate it twice the x-axis
and call this the z-axis and it comes
out bottom point top actually pointing
at you
I did that right so now I'm going to do
the rotation now this one first and then
what was the other rotation that
different answer right totally different
answer and you can't add angles as
vectors doesn't work and it just it's
just a the way I think of it you know
mathematics is largely done to help
describe the physical world Newton and
all those people were figuring out
needed calculus to describe the motion
of the planets vectors were invented to
do analytic geometry and it just doesn't
work for angles you just can't use them
for angles it's just you know the vector
math that they figured out just wasn't
quite clever enough to include angles
however vectors can be applied to
positions velocities accelerations and
angular velocities and angular
accelerations but not angles themselves
that's the basic basic thing you need to
learn from that okay let's use some
multiple frames we're going to do that
today we're going to now apply this and
this and this today to do a prop to do
some problems and let me see where I
want to go first with this
so I have a problem that I wanted to do
and it's a circus ride there's an arm
and that arm is rotating attached to the
arm is a cross piece and a passenger can
sit in each one of these things and this
is basically horizontal you're looking
down on it so you'd be riding around on
these cups at the circus and it's going
around and around and I want I want to
know the velocity it's the velocity of
point B in the O frame and so this has
to do one of the things on this list
might be to get that notation down so
this is the velocity of this is the
point and this is the frame okay so what
can you write down just take 30 seconds
see if you can remember write down the
general velocity formula that was put up
yesterday vector velocity formula for a
point that's at at in a moving frame
that's moving in a fixed frame came up
the general formula had two or three
terms in it and we'll walk our way
through it
I realize I did something maybe slightly
out of order so hold that thought you've
written down what you've got let's we
have to do something before you can
actually write that we haven't actually
picked our reference frames have we all
right so think about that for a second
how would you set up this problem what
would you make translating reference
frames and what would you know you're
rotating translating frame or would you
sign it think about it for 30 seconds
okay who's got a take a shot at it for
me what are we where would you pick
reference frames for this problem
yeah what's your name I'm Ben man
oh and he's long across here here for
sure this is your inertial frame not
moving right okay
and so you would put one up here yeah
okay I get a so I'm going to put a line
I'm gonna line it with a cross and I'm
going to stick out here and call it x2
and then there'd be a y2 here and it
rotates with the cross okay
all right it's pretty good that's it
that's good now go back to that equation
now give me the velocity the general
expression I don't want you to work out
the details just the what it would what
set of terms would you plug things into
now to get the velocity of B and O then
we'll evaluate the terms and talk about
it using now what we've decided here
okay so when you helped me out so what's
on the right-hand side of this equation
first term married put your name you
Stephen Lawson a with respect to o all
right that's the velocity at this point
in this frame right all right what else
do we need
put your name Andre yeah here a velocity
of B with respect to K and what is that
is that influenced by rotation can you
describe what you mean by the velocity
of B na physically so as if you were
stationing sitting in on that frame
right does a rotation have anything to
do with what you see no so this is I
sometimes to remind myself right here
this is omega equals zero and you can
just set that mega equal to zero what
you would see is the it's what this term
is
do we need anything more named Christine
it so if you gave it to me once before
it's gonna take a while it's the
rotational motion
so it's has to be with you mega I've
seen
okay and we have the name of that frame
to help us out this is then frame a X 2
y 2 Z 2 he really want to do right so no
and waiters call it frame a so this
would be our B as in a and these are all
vectors and I often forget to underline
all right do we have it right anybody
you want to add to that fix it correct
it
Steven right
I left it vague on purpose we need to
figure that out he asked you know is it
Omega 2 or Omega 1 really important
point we want to make today about the
what Omega this is we'll get to that
yeah well they're repeating the same
direction
wouldn't it be added in both Omega 2
well okay let's talk about it right now
are we it agreed that this look are we
agreed that this is the right formula
all right then let's set about figuring
it out and like we can talk about this
term first so we want to know this is
the rotation rate of this arm out here
in the base frame is what it seems
that's what the notation says and we
know that the rotation rate of this
first arm and the base frame is this and
we know that the rotation rate of this
thing in the with respect to now we've
met now this has gotten a little
complicated
this isn't quite exact your exact enough
this is Omega 2 with respect to this arm
that's what's given in this problem so
this is a mega 2 with respect to the arm
Oh
a-all right yeah
no I see court system a x2y2 rotates and
if you're sitting in there you wouldn't
see it so this is the totally rotate
what the this is correct it's the
rotation rate at Cena no so we need to
figure out what that is I'm telling you
in this case you were given I could have
you might have been given the rotation
ready to no you weren't
you were given the rotation rate
relative to here so I'll write it as
we're w2 with respect to this arm Oh a
so what how do you get we need Omega and
o is what don't we have here oh this
little vehicle
good but what is it now I'm going to
let's deduce it if my my arm here this
is the first arm and this is that a B
link okay now if Omega with respect to
this arm this thing weren't moving with
there's no rotation rate relative this
the thing whole thing would be straight
right and it's going around like this
what's the rotation rate of the link out
here Omega one okay and now this arms
not moving but this is rotating relative
to it at Omega 2 what's the rotation
rate of the link out here just to make
it 2 if I put the two together what is
the rotation rate of this arm the second
link right Omega 1 in certainly in O
plus Omega 2 it's not with respect to a
I'm just going to call it with respect
to the are maybe even this notation is
failing a little bit but you get what I
mean it's Omega 1 plus Omega 2 and let's
just write it as Omega 1 plus Omega 2
and what direction is it in it's a
vector so one of the things we have to
pay attention to our unit vectors yeah
yeah so this has got a capital I hat
here and a capital J hat there and
coming out of the board okay right
now this is certainly a hat capital K
hat this one knows relative to its the
rotation rate of this thing here is a
reference frame what's sticking out this
way a little k2 right but is it is it
parallel to capital K always parallel to
capital K correct so they're the same
thing
if unit vectors in the parallel they
mount up the same thing so we can put
capital K lowercase K anything we want
here and it's correct okay now we got an
answer for that so when you're given
when one one thing is on its attached to
another and you're given the if out here
you are given the rotation rate in the
base frame you're done but if you're
given the rotation rate relative to some
other moving part then you have to add
them up to get the true rotation rate
that's the bottom line message all right
so we now have we started we're trying
to figure out this expression here and
we figured that we started with one of
the harder terms and we need to figure
out finish to finish it though let's do
this over here we have a velocity of a
in
and we have the velocity of B in a with
no rotation and we have Omega B and O
and let's finish that we know what Omega
is now the whoops is not Omega it's a
third term is omega BN o across R b/a so
now we've gotten the first bit of this
let's finish the problem this is Omega 1
plus Omega 2 times K hat cross with what
we need a length I'll call this l-l-long
so what is our B with respect to a yes L
X 2 hat and I'll call that lj2
the coordinate is X 2 the unit vector
would be I 2 right not a J and I so the
unit vector is I 2
okay great now what is K cross I 2
thank you so we get Omega L Omega 1 plus
Omega 2 J 2 hat that's that term and we
need to figure out our other two terms
what's this term remind yourself of the
meaning this is the velocity of point B
with respect to the a frame which is
attached to it it's on a rigid body he
said a mega to Denzel
she says zero any other I hear another
zero now why don't we meet Y zero right
so this term is always from the point of
view of a person riding on the frame
writing on that frame so you won't ever
see rotation from inside the frame
you're just moving with it okay so
that's it's called
in the Williams book he calls this term
V rel it's the relative loss between
these two points no rotation the so what
is that in this case I hear zero
everybody agree it's zero no motion the
rigid link two points don't move
so now we're just left with this one and
now one of the points I really wanted to
drive home today is in fact this problem
is one depending on how you set it up
you can think of as actually having
multiple rotating frames and if you do
that what's the correct way to add up
the parts so you get to the right answer
because we've left this one for the last
and I want to make sure you go away with
a kind of both of no in the formula you
can
always use and it's going to work and
formula can always use is the wonders of
this form every one of these problems
including multiple links and things you
can build up by doing a sequence of this
problem again and again and again until
you get the whole answer
okay so we've actually done what I would
call the outer problem first we've done
worked out this thing we kind of have to
do the inner problem now we could have
done it a different order but I need to
know the velocity at this point and just
to get you in the habit of using the
vector equation that we have I want to
know the velocity of a in O and I'm
going to attach a rotating frame to this
arm x1 y1 it rotates with this arm at
that rate okay now if I if I and I want
you to use that frame to solve for the
velocity of this point and that would be
velocity of point a you know would be
the this one this this frame now is an O
a little x1 y1 z1 it's a rotating frame
right because the O's are going to get
confusing let's better not call it o
will call there for rotating one in
Williams you use at lower K so it's hard
to do on the board let's call this C so
this is a root frame see x1 y1 so this
frame will be my C frame so I want to
know the velocity of point a it's the
velocity of what
just let me use that pot formula up
there we could put it in the right
points so what's the first term me the
velocity of the sea this point this time
the rotating frame does the rotating
frame translate we have a rotating frame
doesn't have any translational velocity
no but you still have a right to turn
down and set it equal to zero so what's
the right term how do you write it right
put the velocity of my reference frame
it's a translational plus V that
reference frame in the O frame and
that's footage and in this case it's
zero plus
velocity of gap a with respect to C and
I'll remind you again you know it's as
if you were now rotating with it you're
sitting at C looking at a what's its
speed zero plus
Omega 1 Omega scene where measured from
where as you with respect at West ring
all right hero cross wit we need a
length will make this link capital R
scalar so what do we Kirk what's the
cross product here
what's unit vector correct unit vector
not X but X is the co-ordinate the unit
vector is right at term 0 that term 0
this term not Omega 1 and what's the
unit vector associated is Omega 1 K
cross I 1 J 1 at right and so we have R
Omega 1 J 1 hat now we should be able to
write out the full answer of the
velocity of B in O is the bullet
velocity of a which is R Omega 1 J 1 hat
plus the velocity of B with respect to a
which was zero plus the vil of this term
which we figured out as L I go 1 plus
Omega 2 times J 2 hat
so we've done two or three sub this is
kind of a hard problem actually that for
the first time out it has because it has
settle a number of subtle concepts and
built into it you actually have two
rotating bodies how do you deal with
them well you can you do sequential
applications of that vector velocity
formula yeah
so she asked me why did we bother to
make this other frame right cut so the
problems are going to get nastier and
nastier I could have asked you when I
walked into class what is the velocity
at point headed and you will have said
Oh obviously our Omega hey
yeah right you know why are we two going
all this trouble one way that everybody
knows from high school physics that it's
just our Omega and the answer is is
because we're going to get to doing
really nasty problems and I want to make
sure you understand all the subtleties
about how we get these in one that it
even wanted so we started simple but I
did it the long hard way so because of
the but later on if I'd walked in at the
beginning and just asked you right off
the bat what's the velocity of this
point go for it you guys would have
failed miserably
right it's not much harder but it takes
two sequential applications of what you
think is obvious when you walk into
class so that's why we're just doing it
the hard way so that you get all the
little nuances yeah
this
why is it that way you that lies it
we're just going to our Navy and when
you go first with respect to our poet
when I wrote the equation for ill- okay
you say this perspective Oh a lady say
oh I see
hmm because this is wrong right
yeah yes so he has a question and that's
the S&X that's the final subtle point I
want to get to today
good question he's saying are these the
same are they different how do we deal
with it so question for you in general
if you're asked uh given a problem like
we just did and you arrive at a solution
is it okay to give an answer where you
have unit vectors in multiple frames and
neither of these unit vectors are in the
base frame and yet the answer we're
claiming is that this is the velocity of
B in oh and here we got unit vectors
that are not in the base frame is it a
legit equation or not I think
came out of nose out there okay I think
we better figure it out
so we have unit on the arm this is my C
and O here on the arm I have a frame
that rotates with it that has unit
vectors in the direction of the arm of I
1 and J 1 and so let's so here's I one
it's unit long here's the angle theta
here's J 1 and the angle angles and I
want to know this is I 1 this is j-1
can i express i1 and j1 in terms of
capital i capital J the unit vectors in
the base frame I want to express them in
terms of unit vectors that are in this
rigid non-moving non rotating inertial
frame so here is down here this is the I
hat direction this is the J hat
direction right not moving so this is
just a unit thing unit long can I do can
I project it onto its I component and
capital J component alright so I won it
looks to me like cosine theta I hat plus
sine theta J hat degree
standard trig right and this one takes
me a minute to figure this out which is
the theta here this is theta that's 90
minus theta so this must be theta right
so theta here and if this is unit long
what's that that projection there is so
j1 is has two components - sine theta I
plus cosine theta J and I highly
recommend you write that one down
make sure you can drive it yourself
you're going to need it again and again
and again and again now could we do the
same thing for could we convert j2 to
the base frame
and we're it rotates so this x2 can be
at any arbitrary position but what so
you have to in order to do the problem
you have to pick a position and then
you'd have to draw an angle and then you
would have to apply this formula and so
you're going to end up with an eye to is
some cosine fee capital I plus sine B
capital J and the same thing J 2 is
minus sine VI plus cosine theta J so
I'll do it we'll do a trivial example a
trivial I solve a trivial case what is
the instantaneous velocity at the moment
that the coordinate system is lined up
as we see and be and sitting right here
so we got to go look at our but our
answer where was our final answer
velocity of the sky here right what
would be the contribution of this term
to work we have to take each term and
convert it to the base system in capital
IJ terms right you do a one term at time
and add up the components so what is the
how do you break this one down and put
it into capital i capital J components
hmm yeah what's the answer
so Jake if it's lined up like this j2 is
important in what direction
oh and what is that in his system just
capital dick that at this instant time
that's just capital G trivial trivial
calculation because this angle is 90
degrees you plug in 90 degrees this term
goes to zero this term goes to 1 J 2 s
capital J right and what about the other
term J 1 you just got to go with them
it's the first one it's J 1 right so you
just got to go with low it's what it is
this you'd substitute this in for J 1
right here and you'd have R 1 Omega 1
cosine theta sine theta J and K terms
Plus this thing Capital J and you have
just converted the answer which was in
terms of unit vectors in rotating two
different rotating frames you've
converted it all down to the base frame
I I picked I just this is the dupes I'm
sorry I just made a mistake you guys got
to get better catching me that now makes
sense
sophie is the angle that the j2 unit
vector makes with the inertial frame
right and theta is the angle that the j1
or I want to make with inertia print yes
in this case B is 0 yeah did that get
them so work out over there sine of B is
0 and goes
they're always one and you get yeah J
Virginia we did I just but I just you
have to eat there isn't a simple answer
arm and you have to use the full
expression I just got lazy and didn't
want to write it out the answer is this
and you know sick in 30 degrees if you
want and then you'll get numbers right
okay so that real important point that
we've just covered is that the answers
are correct expressed in rotating unit
vectors expressed in different unit
vector different rotating ones this is
correct
because you can take this and you can
reduce it down to the base frame so you
will be usually in problems that you're
given you'll be asked to express the
answer in terms of unit vectors in the
base frame or you be told you can leave
it in your in whatever is your
comfortable set of unit vectors now most
of the time the first ones you'll arrive
at are the ones in terms of the rotating
coordinates that are easier to use you
know the more natural the answer falls
out in terms of these good alright so
and we've got three four minutes left
what have I confuse you with here so key
concepts what if we what hasn't been
clear or we didn't cover it yet another
point it shows those are the starting my
from Springs instead of five hats and
only because at the beginning of class
we talked about it which frames do we
want to use and those we chose those
could we have used a polar coordinate
system to do this problem
sure twice you do it once in each okay
is there a way to know you know up front
which one would simplify down to like
the inner so I had to de have some more
simply you know the easiest way is their
way to no upfront no that's just
experience work lots of problems and you
get good at picking picking frame we can
probably with time as we meet and talk
about these things will come up with
some sort of general insights about how
to do that but yes
this picture is the coordinate system of
that first arm yeah boy wait wait wait
wait no this is the first one that is
theta and these are ones right the
toussis the two system the two system
would be beats okay assuming that was
the rider no this is point hey if you
will not well it could be flying up the
point well then would this is me because
I thought we decided that he was if this
is point a right that is point it all
right and this is an arm see a so is
this one's here the words well look at
whatever the unit vector is the in a
vector in this system is lined up with
that arm and so this is just a breakdown
of the B's unit vector so I could draw
the angles and figure out the sines and
cosines you could draw a similar picture
for iqj tubes and then it would be fees
okay great question yes so since you can
choose between Cartesian or polar
coordinates could you set like one in
Cartesian one
yep is that
Poehler is I don't have time to show you
today but for planar motion problems
which are things confined to a plane
they rotate
they wrote axis of rotations always in
the K direction which is all the
problems that you ever did in 801
physics you didn't do general things
actually but for planar motion problems
polar cordial coordinates actually you
still need the K to describe the
rotation right polar coordinates
cylindrical coordinates are oftentimes
really convenient and they're easy to
use because you've learned them a long
long time ago and you know the relations
right but you can make it a rotating x1
y1 z1 rotating system and it all work
out
I mean what's in this we came up with
this little formula here right this
could just as easily have been our hat
and this could have just as easily been
yeah no difference whatsoever in a
planar motion problem well you know I
attach an XY system that rotates with it
or I call it R and theta these are the
same direction ours in direction of i1
that is in the direction of j1 so
usually when it's convenient and it's
convenient a lot of times especially
that nasty acceleration formula in polar
coordinates it reduces down just to this
set of five terms and memorize it and
just tick them off Coriolis centripetal
it just you see them right away you know
what they are but there are certain
problems even in planar motion problems
that polar coordinates don't work for
doesn't work for a menges terrible day
and what you think about that think it's
actually a simple problem put a dog on a
merry-go-round the dogs running in a
random direction on the merry-go-round
and the merry-go-round is turning at
some rate and you only want one rotating
coordinate system R and theta you can't
do the problem with polar coordinates
think about just go away think about why
not you can't describe tell you
words you go figure it out you can't
describe the velocity of the dog in
polar coordinates the dog is running
around with dogs fixed on the rotating
thing then polar coordinates work so
dogs running you can't do that velocity
so you need a more sophisticated
coordinate system